la séance est reprise l'ordre du jour
appelle le débat sur les urgences
hospitalières et les soins non
programmés
la parole est tout d'abord à l'orateur
du groupe qui a demandé ce débat
monsieur René Paul Savary pour le groupe
les républicains et pour 8 minutes chers
collègues
madame
ministre monsieur madame le Président
mais chers collègues notre groupe a
souhaité inscrire ce débat afin de
permettre au Sénat de connaître les
intentions du Gouvernement en matière de
politique de santé et plus
particulièrement celle concernant les
urgences maillon clé de notre système de
soins
un chiffre peu connu mais que je voulais
souligner la saturation des urgences est
concentrée sur un nombre relativement
faible de patients qui vont en moyenne 5
fois par an aux urgences avec un délai
médian entre deux passages de 40 jours
c'était énorme c'est quelque 3 millions
de patients réguliers des urgences sont
surtout des personnes âgées
polypatologiques des usagers qui n'ont
pas d'autres recours médicaux à
proximité ainsi que des personnes
exclues socialement et bien d'autres cas
également par ailleurs n'oublions pas
qu'en 2019 une grève massive des
urgences a alerter les pouvoirs publics
sur l'état dégradé des services alors
comment sommes-nous arrivés là au fil du
temps des décisions ont été prises qui
peuvent être lourdes conséquences pour
le reconnaître pour certains c'est la
mise en oeuvre des 35 heures il est vrai
qu'on a demandé aux gens de compter leur
temps ce qui a entraîné une désor au
niveau de l'hôpital pour d'autres c'est
la T2A il faut reconnaître également que
la T2A s'est traduit par une course à
l'acte et cette tarification
initialement instauré pour compenser les
difficultés de la dotation globale a eu
un effet inflationniste parfois
et du côté de l'hôpital la difficulté
majeure c'est la question de la valve
des urgences alors ça regroupe un
certain nombre de dispositions
étonnant compte des manques de lit dans
les services spécialisés la pénurie de
place dans des structures
extra-hospitalières et lors des
auditions 2017 par notre commission un
chef de service a bien résumé la
question puisque il disait que le
principal problème n'était pas
d'empêcher les patients de venir aux
urgences mais de réussir à les en faire
sortir l'enjeu de la prise en charge en
aval des urgences et double il s'agit
non seulement d'assurer le
désengorgement de ces dites d'urgences
mais également de garantir le bon
aiguillage des patients vers la
surtructure spécialisée de manière à
éviter le retour aux urgences ou les
hospitalisations multiples les
établissements de santé privés les
médecins de vie ne participent pas tous
également à la prise
le défaut de formation participe
également à cette crise nous aurons je
pense l'occasion dans un reparler et les
médicaux par les cabines et médicaux
pardon par ailleurs
reste peu ouvert le soir pour accueillir
les
urgences à cause là aussi d'une
rémunération peut-être pas suffisante et
puis d'une adaptation de la vie
professionnelle avec la vie familiale et
maintenant il faut en tenir compte bien
sûr dans notre réflexion des points
positifs cependant on peut souligner que
certaines communes en plus en place des
Samy service d'accueil médical initial
service médical de garde ouvert en
soirée le week-end ou des médecins
généralistes se relèvent volontairement
ils traitent les urgences en dehors des
heures d'ouverture des cabinets médicaux
à côté de cela j'aurais échoué souhaité
évoqué la situation post covid qui est
révélaire actrice du malaise de
l'hôpital mais pas uniquement en mars
2020 la pandémie de covid-19 a pro une
vague importante de recours aux soins
qui a mis le secteur hospitalier sous
tension les hôpitaux ont dû s'adapter
pour gérer la flux de patient notamment
dans les services d'urgence avec des
transferts vers d'autres établissements
et la mobilisation de la réserve
sanitaire et ça a tenu le coup après
plus de deux ans de crise sanitaire la
rapport de la commission d'enquête du
Sénat sur la situation de l'hôpital a
pointé cette aggravation du malaise
hospitalier et malgré une reverio
irisation des salaires pour les
personnels soignants selon l'accord de
Ségur la dégradation des conditions de
travail de l'ensemble des personnels à
générer une désaffection qui est
préoccupante à l'égard de l'hôpital les
milliards à injecté n'ont pas produits
les résultats escomptés l'hôpital ce
n'est pas qu'une question d'argent
la médecine libérale également très
engagée dans la crise sanitaire est-elle
même en crise les Français ont de plus
en plus de mal à trouver des médecins
traitants on le sait dans l'immédiat ce
n'est pas l'annonce de la fin du numerus
closus qui va y remédier ni celle de la
quatrième année d'Internet médecine
envisagée pour 2026 en ce qui concerne
le bilan des mesures prises avant l'été
nous noterons que les propositions de la
mission flash sur les urgences sont
principalement axés sur la régulation
elle ne traite pas bien sûr des racines
du mal mais nous l'avions déjà souligné
ce problème de régulation et
l'importance de redonner du corps aux
métiers d'assistant de régulation
médicale madame la ministre il y a des
rendez-vous à ne pas manquer comme la
convention médicale pour permettre aux
médecins de ville de prendre en charge
plus de patients en libérant du temps
médical en revalorisant l'activité
libérale mais également une conférence
on est parti prenante celle-ci doit
associer l'ensemble des corps
intermédiaires des syndicats
professionnels de santé associations des
usagers patients représentant des
collectivités qui n'ont pas souvent été
entendus ni considérer ces dernières
années elle reposera parait-il sur une
approche globale de la santé et de la
restauration de l'éthique dixit le
ministre de la Santé derrière ces termes
bien génériques il est difficile de
cerner l'ambition réformatrice du
gouvernement deux sujets restent majeurs
pour l'avenir de notre système de santé
à savoir bien sûr son financement mais
également sa gouvernance en conclusion
tous ces constats nous amènent à penser
qu'il est nécessaire de réformer
structurellement et profondément notre
système de santé la situation tendue aux
urgences n'est qu'une facette d'un mal
profond aujourd'hui nous ne sommes plus
dans une problématique
aux soins à plusieurs vitesses mais dans
celle de l'accès aux soins tout court
les manifestations s'enchaînent pour
proposer ou trouver des solutions à
l'accès aux soins
urgents de la population et nous sommes
persuadés que c'est au niveau des
territoires avec les acteurs du soin et
de la prévention avec les patients avec
les élus que doivent être élaborés des
réponses concrètes et pérennes voici
quelques éléments que je souhaitais au
nom de mon groupe formulés en préambule
madame la ministre vous qui vous
déplacez sur les territoires nous avons
eu l'honneur de vous recevoir vous qui
êtes spécifiquement chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé entendez notre
message et n'hésitez pas à nous à nous
exposer vos ambitions pour cette
mandature je vous en remercie
merci
la parole est à Madame Agnès Firmin le
Bodo ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé et pour une durée
de 8 minutes maximum
madame la Présidente Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs je
suis honoré de m'exprimer devant le
Sénat sur un sujet qui nous tient tout
particulièrement à coeur et qui est au
centre des préoccupations quotidiennes
de nos concitoyens pour ce débat sur les
urgences hospitalières et soins non
programmés
les difficultés que cristallise nos
urgences sont le symptôme aigu d'une
crise plus large qui touche l'ensemble
de notre système de santé celle de
l'accès aux soins nos urgences sont
ainsi le point de convergence des
fragilités structurelles qui parcourent
notre système de santé démographique
médicale inadaptée difficulté
d'articulation entre la ville et
l'hôpital perte d'attractivité et de
sens de certains métiers désertification
médicale un système de santé qui doit
pourtant a bien des égards faire notre
fierté en effet nous pouvons en être
fiers de notre système de santé fier des
valeurs d'égalité et d'universalité sur
laquelle il est fondé nous pouvons être
fiers de notre système de santé qui a
fait preuve une remarquable résilience
pendant les vagues successives de covid
qui ont ébranlé notre pays à ce titre je
pense qu'il n'est pas excessif de saluer
une fois encore la mobilisation
exemplaire de nos soignants
la crise des soins non programmés et les
difficultés d'accès mettent en péril
l'essence même de ce système de santé
qui est notre héritage commun nous nous
devons d'entreprendre les réformes
nécessaires pour le préserver autant
pour faire face aux défis du présent que
pour les générations à venir dans cette
perspective la première urgence consiste
assurément à repenser l'organisation de
la prise en charge des soins non
programmés les attentes des
professionnels de santé comme de nos
concitoyens sont fortes et légitimes en
la matière le gouvernement a répondu
présent dès son installation les 41
mesures opérationnelles de la mission
flash menée par le ministre et médecin
urgentiste François Brown avant sa
nomination ont permis de mobiliser des
leviers nouveaux pour répondre au défi
immédiat des urgences durant la période
cruciale de l'été
je le dis sans triomphalisme et avec la
gravité qui s'y est à ce sujet la
catastrophe annoncée ne s'est pas
produite et notre système de santé à
globalement tenu certes cela ne fut pas
sans effort et nous devons avant tout
saluer la mobilisation des
professionnels et de nos administrations
impliquées dans la mise en œuvre de ces
mesures transitoires dont certaines
pourraient être rapidement pérennisé en
effet l'Inspection générale des affaires
sociales Ligas vient de remettre un
rapport d'évaluation de ces solutions
nous sommes en train d'instruire les
données de cette évaluation et allons
prochainement réunir une nouvelle fois
le comité de suivi d'ici une dizaine de
jours pour travailler sur les mesures à
conserver nous pouvons cependant déjà
tirer un bilan positif de ces mesures
elles ont mobilisé les professionnels
dans une logique de responsabilité
collective partagée entre la ville et
l'hôpital elles ont enfin sensibilisé
nos concitoyens à la fragilité du
système de santé en général et des soins
nos pratiques non programmées en
particulier générant des premiers
changements notables de comportement
chez les Français notamment dans le
recours aux urgences et l'appel
préalable au 15
une idée forte de cette mission sur
lequel je tiens à assister et de
retrouver le sens de ce que signifie
urgent une urgence médicale se définit
d'une façon précise qu'il a distingue
par nature d'un soin non programmé c'est
une situation requérant une intervention
médicale immédiate afin de secourir une
personne dont le pronostic vital ou
fonctionnel est susceptible d'être
engagé l'urgence relève ainsi
nécessairement d'une décision médicale
et répond à des critères stricts et
limitatifs or au cours des 20 dernières
années le nombre de passages aux
urgences a plus que doublé nous le
savons ces publics qui se présentent aux
urgences sont en partie et même souvent
ceux qui n'ont pas accès autrement à
notre système de santé parce qu'ils
n'ont pas médecin traitant parce qu'ils
ne parviennent pas à obtenir un
rendez-vous dans un délai rassurant
c'est en cela que les urgences sont
comme je le disais un symptôme du
malaise que nous connaissons
nos urgences sont en quelque sorte
victimes de leur succès et cela pèse sur
la sécurité des patients l'inflation du
recours crée des situations
d'engorgement et le temps de passage aux
urgences à de ce fait beaucoup augmenté
il n'est pas question de limiter ou de
restreindre de quelques manières que ce
soit l'accès aux soins encore moins de
filtrer ou de trier les malades comme
certains ont pu le laisser entendre
parfois certes sous l'effet d'une
inquiétude légitime mais parfois guidé
par des motifs politiques il s'agit donc
de replacer chacun dans son rôle le long
de la chaîne de prise en charge afin de
se donner les moyens de proposer à
chacun à chaque patient le parcours de
soins le plus adapté à sa condition
concentrez les urgences sur leur cœur de
mission et leur plus-value nécessite
ainsi un travail de régulation
pluridimensionnel que nous avons mis en
place la meilleure orientation dans le
système de santé a fait l'objet d'une
campagne de sensibilisation sur le bon
usage des services d'urgence il est en
effet important de faire évoluer les
mentalités d'où cette campagne menée
depuis plusieurs mois pour inviter nos
concitoyens à contacter avant toute
chose le 15 pour être orienté vers la
meilleure solution à leurs
problématiques de santé pour reprendre
un slogan de l'assurance maladie que
nous avons tous encore à l'esprit les
urgences c'est comme les antibiotiques
c'est pas automatique
cet effort de pédagogie est couplé à une
mise à niveau des effectifs d'assistants
de régulation médicale arm dans les
samues centre 15 et un renforcement du
déploiement du service d'accès aux soins
notamment par leur ouverture à
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
pour favoriser le développement des
filières directes de prise en charge
dans d'autres spécialités médicales
en effet la régulation des urgences est
un sujet transversal qui dépasse les
murs des hôpitaux et doit mobiliser
l'ensemble du système de soins par
optimisation du temps médical et
l'augmentation des capacités de réponse
non programmées en ville le comité de
suivi de la mission flash nous a permis
d'avoir en continu un tour d'horizon du
déploiement des applications et de
l'effet de nos mesures en ce sens ainsi
nous savons que les mesures dérogatoires
de l'été ont permis de faciliter le
recrutement d'assistants de régulation
médicale ces professionnels ont alors
plus orienté les patients dont l'état le
justifiait vers des cabinets médicaux en
ville ou des maisons médicales de garde
dont le nombre de maisons ouvertes le
samedi matin à quasiment doublé sur la
période considérée sur prescription de
la régulation les ambulanciers ont
d'ailleurs pu être mobilisés en assurant
un transport sanitaire des patients
versés structures
preuve de la nécessité de renforcement
des effectifs et du succès de la
démarche le nombre de recours au 15 a
augmenté de 20% au cours de l'été
l'appel au 15 est en train de devenir un
réflexe et c'est ce que nous souhaitons
et nous avons assumé la responsabilité
d'absorber cette hausse notamment en
donnant toute leur place au médecin
réguliero régulateur le renforcement des
équipes de régulation est ainsi une
mesure que nous avons souhaité inscrire
dans le temps long dès le projet de loi
de finance de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 dans le budget de la Sécurité
sociale qui arrivera très prochainement
devant votre assemblée nous renforçons
en effet les équipes médicales en charge
de la régulation grâce à deux leviers
nous encourageons la reprise d'activité
des médecins retraités sur des activités
de régulation médicale téléphonique en
les faisant bénéficier du régime
simplifié des professions médicales ce
qui Falise facilite les démarches
administratives nous permettons à tout
médecin participants à la régulation en
dehors de la permanence des soins
ambulatoires de bénéficier de la
couverture assurantielle de
l'établissement support du centre de
régulation pour éviter que les médecins
n'aient à souscrire individuellement un
contrat d'assurance ce qui était une de
leur
revendications ancienne le PLFSS
comporte par ailleurs une autre module
forte liée aux urgences qui est
l'exonération du ticket médérateur sur
les transports sanitaires urgents
préhospitaliers cette mesure s'inscrit
dans notre politique volontariste en
faveur de l'accès aux soins dans un
contexte d'urgence en supprimant le
reste à charge de bénéficiaires qui
n'auront plus rien à débourser tout cela
est efficace puisque le nombre de
passages aux urgences toutes causes
confondues a baissé de fait de mesure de
l'ordre de 5% à l'été 2022 par rapport à
l'année dernière c'est un progrès
concret et une tendance encourageante
que nous devons confirmer et approfondir
un autre chantier majeur que nous devons
nous être celui de la pénibilité du
travail de nuit que la mission flash sur
les urgences et soit nos programmés a
reconnu pour la première fois celle-ci a
été mieux valorisée grâce à la
majoration des indemnités de nuit pour
les personnels non médicaux et la
majoration des indemnités de garde pour
les personnels médicaux
je tiens également à souligner que la
hausse du point d'indice à hauteur de 3
et de maths
merci notre ambition avec le ministre de
la santé et de la prévention et de
fonder un nouveau modèle pour répondre
toujours mieux aux besoins de santé de
nos concitoyens partout sur le
territoire aujourd'hui et demain je vous
invite donc à participer au CNR en santé
qui aura lieu dans vos régions
respectivement je vous remercie merci
alors dans la suite du débat s'il vous
plaît chaque orateur dispose de deux
minutes maximum y compris l'éventuelle
réplique
et le gouvernement madame la ministre
dispose pour répondre d'une durée
équivalente de deux minutes maximum
le gouvernement aura la faculté si le
juge nécessaire de répondre à une
réplique pendant une minute et l'auteur
de la question disposera alors à son
tour du droit de répondre pendant une
minute et je passe tout de suite la
parole à Madame Patricia Schillinger
pour le groupe du Rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes faisaient
indépendants merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
affaiblis par deux ans de crise
sanitaire notre système de santé a connu
cet été une situation de tension majeure
les services d'urgence menacés de ne
pouvoir assurer la continuité des soins
durant la période estivale si les
difficultés rencontrées par ces services
se sont que des que le symptôme d'une
crise plus large touchant notre système
de soins à l'hôpital il a fallu
rapidement trouver des solutions la
mission flash commandée par le Président
de la République a ainsi formulé de
nombreuses recommandations l'une d'elles
consistait en la possibilité de réguler
les entrées au service d'urgence de
manière orienter les patients dont
l'état de santé ne révèle pas de la
médecine d'urgence vers une offre de
soins adaptés l'engorgement des urgences
se voit ainsi aggraver par la
désertification médicale de nombreux
passons se tournent en effet vers les
urgences pour des soins auxquels
pourraient répondre la médecine de ville
ou d'autres professionnels de santé la
mission flash a notamment fait le choix
d'accroître le recours à la télémédecine
dont la crise sanitaire a mis en
évidence la pertinence et les bienfaits
plus largement le numérique constitue un
vivier potentiel d'outils qui demeure en
France largement sous exploité le
Danemark peut nous inspirer en effet en
s'appuyant largement sur ses nouveaux
outils l'hôpital et la médecine de ville
sont utilisés en complémentarité tout en
préservant les caractéristiques
d'universalité d'accessibilité madame la
ministre quelle place entendez-vous
accordé à l'innovation numérique dans la
transformation nécessaire de notre
système de santé et pensez-vous
poursuivre le développement du recours à
la télémédecine dans le but de répondre
de manière pérenne à la crise des
urgences merci merci madame la ministre
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
le recours à la télémédecine c'est
beaucoup développé depuis la crise
sanitaire vous l'avez souligné
l'expérience danoise que vous citez peut
je crois
utilement nous inspirer les gaz dans le
rapport sur l'évaluation des mesures de
l'été a d'ailleurs mené un travail de
comparaison avec le système danois qui
fait de la régulation préalable une
condition d'accès aux urgences les
téléconsultations constituent un outil
intéressant pour favoriser l'accès aux
soins dans les territoires les moins
bien dotés et une facilité
supplémentaire pour tous le gouvernement
a d'ailleurs soutenu le développement de
cette téléconsultation puisqu'elles ont
été prises à 100% à partir du début de
la crise sanitaire jusqu'au 30 septembre
2022 les téléconsultations ont
représenté en 2021 environ 5% du nombre
total des consultations des médecins
généralistes par ailleurs dans le cadre
des mesures de l'été 2022 faisant suite
aux recommandations de la mission flash
sur les urgences et les soins non
programmés le recours aux unités mobiles
de téléconsultation a été encouragé dans
des situations qui ne relèvent pas de
l'urgence vitale il une infirmière au
domicile du patient pour organiser une
téléconsultation et assurer un premier
niveau de prise en charge du patient si
nécessaire le rapport de ligase sur
l'évaluation de ces mesures souligne
l'intérêt de ces téléconsultation dans
ces situations ne donne pas lieu un
passage aux urgences au spécialisation
dans 75 % des cas c'est donc bien un
outil qui permet d'éviter des passages
aux urgences néanmoins nous souhaitons
maîtriser le développement de la
télémédecine d'abord parce que nous
devons rester vigilants à ce qu'une
possibilité de prise en charge physique
puisse toujours être garantie pour les
situations des soins urgents ou de soins
non programmés ensuite parce qu'il ne
faut pas que le développement de la tel
médecine Vienne retirer des médecins
implantés dans les territoires pour les
spécialiser sur un exercice
exclusivement digital enfin nous devons
lutter contre les dérives que nous
voyons apparaître avec le recours à la
téléconsultation c'est pour soi c'est
pourquoi dans le PLFSS nous limitons la
prescription d'arrêt de travail en
téléconsultation au seul médecin
traitant ou un médecin déjà connu du
patient face aux abus qui ont pu être
détectés dans cette certaines situations
madame Sillinger vous avez non merci
alors la parole est à Madame Annie Le
HOUEROU pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègue personnel épuisé surmené
accroissement des départs en cours de
carrière difficulté de recrutement
l'hôpital public est en crise sans
précédent malgré les revalorisations
salariale la dégradation des conditions
de travail cumulées à la difficulté
d'accès aux soins aux soins en ville
provoque l'engorgement voir la
saturation des urgences et la fermeture
de services l'accès aux soins
s'annonçait très problématique ce début
d'été vous amenant à un plan pour les
urgences et pour les soins non
programmés selon vous des réponses
rapides et fortes pour l'été une
régulation de l'accès aux urgences via
le 15 une plus grande disponibilité des
professionnels déjà très éprouvés la
mobilisation des Hospitaliers va des
majorations de rémunération la recherche
d'une meilleure coordination des acteurs
déjà très mobilisés ne sont que des
réponses conjoncturelles pour que notre
système de santé passe l'été l'été est
passé si le pire souvent été évité
parfois pas c'est grâce au dévouement à
la mobilisation sans faille des
personnels soignants à qui je témoigne
ici de notre grande reconnaissance les
recommandations de la mission flash ont
été insuffisantes et ne permettent pas
d'assurer un fonctionnement sécurisé et
optimal pour une prise en charge de
qualité les difficultés rencontrées sont
caractéristique d'une crise profonde du
système de soins et de l'hôpital madame
la ministre quels sont vos propositions
pérennes durables garantissant un accès
aux soins à tous quel que soit l'endroit
où il se trouve sur notre territoire
national concerté au travers du Conseil
national de la refondation par des
réunions de 400 personnes comme moment
comme au moment hier pour imaginer la
solution innovantes ne me paraît pas
être une méthode efficace le diagnostic
est partagé nous l'avons vu dans vos
propos il est urgent de décider de la
refondation de notre système de santé au
service des patients d'abord et
permettant aux soignants
exercer dans la sérénité quel est votre
calendrier et pour quelle priorité
d'action vous remerciez merci même la
ministre
madame la Présidente
nous devons répondre à cette question de
manière globale en ne regardant pas
seulement le fonctionnement des urgences
nos services d'urgence font des faces à
des tensions majeures qui reflètent les
difficultés de notre système de santé en
effet les urgences se retrouvent à la
jonction entre les difficultés en amont
de la ville et les difficultés en
avalent des services hospitaliers pour
améliorer durablement la situation nous
devons mieux répondre à la demande
croissante de soins non programmés et
non urgent qui contribuent à
l'engorgement massif de nos urgences il
y a tout d'abord les services d'accès
aux soins ce service se déploie
progressivement sur le territoire
national et à vocation à pouvoir aider
les citoyens à s'orienter dans le
système de santé pour le patient
confronté et un besoin de soins non
programmés et lorsque l'accès à son
médecin traitant n'est pas possible ou
s'il n'a pas de médecin traitant le sas
permet d'accéder par téléphone à un
professionnel de santé ce dernier pourra
lui fournir un conseil médical lui
proposer une téléconsultation l'orienter
selon la situation vers une consultation
de noix de soins non programmés en ville
vers un service d' déclencher
l'intervention d'un SMUR selon son état
de santé l'objectif d'un sas est
d'apporter une réponse pour des besoins
de soins urgents ou de soins non
programmés sous 48 heures lorsque le
médecin traitant ou un médecin de
proximité n'est pas disponible en
première intention il repose sur la mise
en place d'une chaîne de son lisible et
coordonnée entre les acteurs de santé de
l'hôpital et de la ville d'un même
territoire incluant une prise en charge
des appels des patients communes entre
les médecins urgentistes et les médecins
généralistes une mobilisation des
médecins généralistes et facteurs pour
prendre en charge
en journée les patients préalablement
réguliers par le sas nous devons
accélérer le déploiement du sas sur tout
le territoire national en 2023 c'est une
nécessité nous savons aussi que nous
devons travailler notamment sur
l'attractivité des métiers pour
favoriser le maintien des professionnels
de l'urgence dans leur domaine
d'activité par ailleurs il n'y aura pas
de solution unique mais un panel de
mesure qui sera à décliner sur chaque
territoire hier c'était le lancement du
CNR devant 400 personnes c'était pas les
ateliers de travail qui ont lieu le
vendredi la méthode du CNR c'est ce qui
s'est passé vendredi au Mans des
ateliers de 15-20 personnes qui
travaillent pour apporter des solutions
la parole est à Madame Laurence Cohen
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologiste merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues avec plus de 20 millions de
passages par an les services des
urgences dans les hôpitaux sont
confrontés à de graves problèmes
d'engorgement du fait d'un manque criant
de généraliste et d'une pénurie de
personnel hospitalier qui démissionne
massivement pour ne plus subir la
maltraitance institutionnelle de
décennies d'austérité de moyens humains
et financiers 10 000 médecins sont
formés chaque année comme en 1975 madame
la ministre or depuis 47 ans la
population a augmenté de 30% avec des
besoins plus importants car elle est
vieillissante et présente des
polypathologies le président de la
République a confié au docteur Braun
future ministre une énième mission flash
dont j'avais avec mon groupe critiqué
l'utilité puisque les conseils et les
propositions alternatives sont connues
depuis des années et les rapports y
compris du Sénat ont tous pointé le
désengagement financier de l'État dans
les hôpitaux à le ministre Braun la
boîte à outils de 41 recommandations a
permis de sauver le système alors que ce
sont les personnels qu'ils l'ont sauvé
au prix d'un épuisement et d'une
dégradation subie des conditions de
prise en charge des malades madame la
ministre que pensez-vous de notre
proposition d'un service public de soins
primaires construit autour d'un réseau
de centre de santé pluri professionnel
allez vous et rétablir l'obligation de
la permanence des soins ville hôpital
pour tous les médecins y compris les
spécialistes exerçant dans le privé
merci madame la ministre
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
tout d'abord la boîte à outils et ses 40
mesures d'urgence ont permis de tenir
bon c'est très clairement ce que nous
disons avec beaucoup d'humilité oui
la boîte
la boîte à outils a permis de tenir bon
grâce à l'investissement des personnels
et je crois l'avoir dit très clairement
la place des centres de santé dans la
permanence des soins doit être renforcée
nous avons commencé à en parler avec les
représentants des centres de santé qui
s'ils partagent le principe d'une
participation mettent en avant deux
difficultés logistiques que nous devons
travailler avec eux les charges
logistiques tout d'abord ouvrir un
centre de santé aux horaires de la
permanence des soins nécessite une
logistique lourde car il faut également
ouvrir l'accueil et le fonctionnement de
la structure même s'il y a un seul
cabinet médical médical de permanence
une des solutions identifiées pour être
d'effectuer cette permanence dans une
maison médicale de garde
la rémunération de l'astreinte les
personnels intervenants dans ces centres
de santé sont salariés et les
rémunérations sont aujourd'hui versées à
l'employeur ces sujets ne sont pas
insurmontables et nous souhaitons les
travailler dans la concertation avec les
représentants des professionnels de
santé pour trouver les voies et moyens
de permettre au Centre de santé de mieux
s'insérer dans la permanence des soins
le principe est clair nous souhaitons
que tous les médecins d'un territoire
participent de manière équitable à la
permanence des soins pour mieux partager
l'effort et faire vivre cette logique de
responsabilité collective
madame Cohen vous avez 35 secondes oui
je me réjouis que vous souteniez
effectivement l'effort des centres de
santé j'espère que vous allez aider à ce
qu'il se développe dans tous les
territoires ce serait déjà une première
chose j'entends également que vous allez
discuter pour qu'il y ait des gares qui
soient prises par les médecins qui
travaillent dans le privé et bien
écoutez c'est une bonne chose il faut je
crois que c'est le décret Mattei qu'il
faut faire sauter mais il faut agir en
amont madame la ministre il y a 6
millions de Français qui n'ont pas de
médecins traitant et il faut agir en
aval parce que le dernier chiffre que
vous avez publié 4300 lits supprimés en
2021 n'est pas de nature à nous rassurer
donc madame la ministre au lieu de
simplement vous abriter derrière les 41
mesures de cette mission flash il faut
vraiment aller plus loin plus vite il y
a eu la parole est à madame Jocelyne
Guinness pour le groupe Union centriste
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues force de constater
comme tous comme nous tous deux réalités
d'abord l'engrangement des services
d'urgence avec des conséquences
enchaînent sur l'hôpital et sur la
qualité de vie au travail des soignants
ensuite le problème d'accès aux soins
dans les territoires face à ces
difficultés je voudrais mentionner le
rapport législatif de ma collègue
Isabelle Doisneau concernant la création
de points d'accueil pour soins immédiat
madame 10 je rappelle que c'est basé
n'aurait pas vocation ajouté un étage ou
millefeuille puisqu'il s'appuierait sur
les structures existantes les
dispositions de cette proposition
permettrait au directeur général de
l'agence régionale de santé de labellisé
pour 5 ans sur l'initiative des
soignants des structures destinées à
prendre en charge des soins non
programmés ces points d'accueil seraient
créés sur plusieurs conditions en
particulier leur inscription dans un
projet territorial de santé ou le projet
de santé dune ou plusieurs communautés
professionnelles terribles territoriales
de santé c'est pas dit assuré une prise
en charge intermédiaire entre le cabinet
médical et le service d'urgence pour des
soins qui ne relèvent pas de l'urgence
médicale comme la petite traumatologie
et contribuerait ainsi à la permanence
des soins le cas échéant le SAMU
pourrait orienter soit vers un passif
soit vers les services d'urgence avec
mes collègues du groupe Union centriste
je souhaiterais savoir madame la
ministre si le gouvernement conserve
comme son prédécesseur un avis favorable
quant à ce dispositif voir si son visage
de la propriété je vous remercie merci
madame la ministre
dans la présidente madame la sénatrice
la réponse aux soins non programmée doit
être améliorée c'est une nécessité elle
manque de visibilité pour nos
concitoyens même si le service d'accès
aux soins en cours de déploiement
facilite l'accès à une consultation non
programmée la proposition de loi basique
contient des éléments intéressants pour
permettre de rendre plus visible les
solutions alternatives aux urgences il
convient cependant d'être vigilant face
aux solutions qui spécialistes des
professionnels de santé dans la réponse
aux soins immédiat en effet les premiers
retours disponibles il apparaît que
certains centres de soins immédiats
n'assurent pas le rôle du médecin
traitant or face au développement des
pathologies chroniques nous devons
consolider la place du médecin traitant
et le tenir informé les points d'accueil
pour son immédiat doivent découler d'un
projet d'organisation partagé entre tous
les acteurs d'un même territoire il
paraît important que ces points
d'accueil émergent plus particulièrement
au sein des CPTs et on étroite
articulations avec les organisations
ambulatoires et les établissements du
territoire et non pas concurrence il
convient aussi d'éviter que ce type de
structure constitue un appel d'air pour
les médecins urgentistes alors même que
les services d'urgence ont du mal à les
recruter enfin pour améliorer la réponse
en soi non programmés je souhaite que
nous puissions trouver des solutions
locales qui permettent une large partie
participation du plomb grand nombre des
professionnels de santé au dispositif de
permanence des soins plus aucune de
plutôt que d'une spécialisation d'un
petit nombre ainsi notre proposition est
de travailler un meilleur encadrement
des structures qui se spécialise dans le
soin immédiat
merci Madame guidez vous avez 30
secondes non merci donc la parole est
donc à Madame Véronique Guillotin pour
le groupe du Rassemblement démocratique
et social européen merci
la question va être un peu près
similaire et je souhaitais effectivement
vous vous interroger sur les centres de
soins non programmés ou centre de soins
immédiats qui ont commencé effectivement
à s'installer sur de nombreux
territoires ils prennent en charge sans
rendez-vous des patients dans un état
peu grave ils ont à leur disposition du
petit matériel technique et permettre la
plupart du temps d'éviter un passage aux
urgences nous en avions débattu il y a
deux ans à l'initiative du groupe Union
centriste et sur la base d'une
proposition de loi venue de l'Assemblée
j'y étais à l'époque pas spécialement
favorable un an après la vote le vote de
la loi ma santé 2022 et alors que le
Ségur se mettait en place nous avions
effectivement à l'époque toutes les
raisons d'espérer depuis malheureusement
la situation ne s'est pas vraiment
améliorée ce week-end encore aux
urgences d'un des hôpitaux de mon
territoire une jeune fille de 18 ans a
passé plus de 36 heures seul un problème
de vertèbres sur un brancard aux
urgences et je parle pas d'un lit dans
un box mais on voit bien que la
situation est compliquée et selon les
soignants ils ont qualifié ce week-end
de week-end comme jamais dans ce
contexte toutes les initiatives me
semblent-ils qui visent à mieux prendre
en charge le bon patient au bon endroit
doivent être soutenus et le modèle de
centre de santé non programmé divise le
ministre tutelle Monsieur François
Beaune n'a d'ailleurs pas caché ses
réticences sur le sujet alors certes ces
prises en charge se font hors parcours
de soins mais comme la prise en charge
aux urgences d'ailleurs avec un modèle
économique je vous l'accorde peut
satisfaisant pour le moment et des
professionnels ayant parfois renoncé à
leur pratique hospitalière pour des
conditions de travail plus acceptables
ils ont la conviction mais je la partage
que l'insertion de ces centres de soins
non programmés si on y va et qu'on mette
des conditions nécessaires dans un
paysage sanitaire et dans l'offre de
soins de chaque territoire peut se faire
à condition que l'on trouve en
concertation un modèle pérenne pour ces
structures aussi j'aimerais connaître
madame la ministre des intentions du
Gouvernement pour que ces centres de
soins n'ont programmé s'intègrent dans
notre système de santé sur la base d'un
modèle qui soit accepté et acceptable
pour l'ensemble de la chaîne de soins
merci madame la ministre
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
les centres médicaux de soins immédiats
sont un objet relativement similaires au
point d'accueil pour soin immédiats
évoqué par votre collègue précédemment
leur développement peut être bénéfique
je l'ai déjà dit c'est notamment le cas
des centres de temporaires qui ont pu se
monter cet été souvent à l'initiative de
personnel de santé libéraux désireux
d'offrir une offre de soins non
programmés afin de soulager les tensions
dans les services d'urgence ces
initiatives peuvent également avoir des
effets regrettables en spécialisant des
ressources médicales sur des prises en
charge aiguës et en délaissant les
patients ayant besoin d'un suivi
chronique c'est un véritable écueil en
effet certains de ces centres indiquent
clairement refusé d'être le médecin
traitant des patients or nous souhaitons
remettre le rôle du médecin traitant au
centre des parcours de prise en charge
ces centres médicaux de soins immédiat
doivent découler d'un projet
d'organisation partagée entre tous les
acteurs d'un même territoire donc il est
important je le redis que ces projets
puissent s'articuler autour des CPTs et
sans doute peut-être que la prise en
charge de soins immédiat serait plus
effective il convient aussi d'éviter je
les redis mais c'est parce que c'est
important de le redire que ce type de
structure constitue un appel d'air pour
les médecins urgentistes alors même que
les services d'urgence ont du mal à les
recruter et vous avez souligné ce fait
vous-même notre position est donc de
travailler un meilleur encadrement de
ces structures qui se spécialise dans le
soin immédiat
merci Madame le Ministre la parole est à
Madame Dominique exposita sonne pour le
groupe les républicains
merci merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre le 11 juillet dernier un pic
de 310 admissions a été enregistrée en
une seule soirée au CHU de Nice ce flux
a pu être régulé une extrémiste grâce au
filtrage médical efficace du s'amuser
aussi ce qui a réorienté les patients
vers 5 autres hôpitaux du département ou
vers des cliniques privées les plus
grandes inquiétudes ont plané tout l'été
avec bien sûr la forte influence
estivale aggravant la saturation
quotidienne déjà constatée malgré
l'engagement sans faille de l'ensemble
des professionnels de santé qui œuvrent
avec dévouement pour soigner au mieux
toutes les personnes qui se présentent
la situation reste très préoccupante
l'organisation en sous-effectif fait
craindre à tout moment un défaut de
vigilance médicale et les professionnels
de santé sont en souffrance d'une charge
de travail toujours plus grande
banalisant l'inacceptable puisque
certains patients restent plusieurs sur
des brancards à cela s'ajoutent les
violences dans son victime les
professionnels de santé en raison
surtout des temps d'attente plusieurs
agressions ont été constatées au CHU
pasteur de Nice à l'hôpital Lenval mais
également à Cannes alors madame la
ministre non comme notre système de
santé n'a pas globalement tenu comme
vous l'avez dit dans vos propos non oui
notre système de santé est en train de
s'effondrer nous n'avons pas besoin d'un
nouveau diagnostic mais que
proposez-vous concrètement comment
entendez-vous mobiliser durablement les
médecins de ville pour épauler les
structures hospitalières allez-vous
entendre enfin les demandes de SOS
médecins dont le réseau ne cesse de se
déliter dans les territoires alors que
les structures locales sont de nature à
éviter l'embolisation des services
d'urgence
merci madame la ministre
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
je tiens tout d'abord à redire oui que
c'était les urgences ont tenu la
catastrophe annoncée n'a pas eu lieu
elles ont tenu grâce à la forte
mobilisation de nos soignants elles ont
fortement tenu grâce à la mobilisation
de nos soignants que je souhaite
vivement remercier de fait les
établissements sont parvenus à organiser
leur fonctionnement en se saisissant des
opportunités qui leur étaient offertes
d'aménager les parcours des patients et
des mesures prises pour valoriser la
pénibilité du travail
s'agissant de la situation du CHU de
Nice le secteur des urgences a fait face
à une activité soutenue en juillet et en
août 230 passages en moyenne par jour ce
pic d'activité combiné aux difficultés
de ressources on conduit début juillet à
une seule occasion à la mise en place
d'une procédure de fermeture partielle
du service des urgences de Nice pendant
5 heures la solidarité territoriale vous
l'avez souligné cet exercice a permis un
rétablissement rapide des conditions
normales de prise en charge en
réorientant moins de patient pendant ce
cours intervalle sur près de 14.000
passages sur la période estivale au plan
national à la faveur d'une grande
communication nationale le nombre de
passages aux urgences à des crus de
manière sensible ce qui constitue un
actif réel et certainement le plus
marquant du plan été avec moins de 5% de
passage aux urgences en miroir le nombre
d'appels aucun a augmenté
significativement le sujet n'est pas
celui des moyens qu'on ne donnerait pas
aux services d'urgence le sujet est
d'abord celui des postes vacants non
pourvu faute de candidats les médecins
urgentistes choisissent ainsi parfois
d'autres modes d'exercices et il nous
faut travailler sur les conditions de
travail pour favoriser le maintien des
personnels en poste attirer les jeunes
médecins et faire revenir ceux qui sont
partis enfin il faut le souligner les
initiatives remarquables mises en place
dans plusieurs territoires en
particulier celle autour d'une
mobilisation renforcée des
professionnels paramédicaux télémédecine
embarquées astreinte d'infirmières
libérales ainsi que la collaboration
entre professionnels
compte parmi les enjeux de la reconquête
du tant soignant dans nos territoires
ces initiatives doivent être fortement
soutenues et leur passage à l'échelle
encouragée car elle permet de décharger
les services d'urgence de passage
évitables en mobilisant utilement
l'ensemble des composantes de notre
système de santé merci
vous avez 15 secondes alors je le répète
tenter va mal il s'effondre il faut
guérir le malade avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard
merci la parole est à Monsieur Daniel
Chassin pour le groupe Les Indépendants
madame la présidente Madame la miss mes
chers collègues les services d'urgence
hospitalier sont un maillon clé de notre
système de soins chaque année près d'un
Français sur 6 se rend aux urgences or
les urgences hospitalières se trouve
actuellement dans une situation critique
en effet tout en continuant à assurer
une prise en charge de pointe elles sont
confrontées un personnel souvent
soignant souvent en sous-effectif et la
carence de lit d'aval ainsi faute de lit
les patients vont emboliser les services
d'urgence qui se trouvent déjà sous
tension la problématique bien sûr c'est
d'assurer les besoins de santé des
Français l'égalité d'accès aux soins sur
l'ensemble de territoire
et la prise en charge d'une partie
croissante de soins non programmé Dieu à
un manque de médecins libéraux madame la
ministre en premier lieu quelle réponse
concrète entendez-vous apporter afin de
remanier à la pénurie d'infirmières qui
conduit à fermer des lits d'aval par
manque de personnel et qui entraîne une
embolisation des urgences que
comptez-vous faire également pour qu'il
y ait davantage de médecins urgentiste
et d'infirmières au sein des urgences
hospitalières en second lieu
envisagez-vous de mettre l'accent sur un
service de soins non programmés pour les
cas peu graves en amont tout proche du
service des urgences afin désengorger
celle-ci enfin quelle solution tendez
vous mettre en oeuvre afin d'avoir plus
de médecins généralistes dans les
maisons de santé pluridisciplinaire ne
faudrait-il pas obliger des médecins en
dernière année de troisième cycle à
effectuer 6 mois supplémentaires de ça
se passe dans les services déficitaires
dans les territoires déficitaires en
maison de santé un médecin référent soit
un an en incluant les six derniers mois
mais avec un classement en médecins
assistant pour avoir la même
rémunération que le médecin installé
merci merci madame la ministre
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Sénateur nos services d'urgence font
face à des tensions majeures ça a été
déjà plusieurs fois qui reflète des
difficultés de notre système de santé en
effet les urgences se retrouvent à la
jonction entre les difficultés en amont
de la ville et les difficultés en
avalent des services hospitaliers nous
avons de trop nombreux postaux vacants
mais je tiens à le souligner pour éviter
tout ambiguïté non par manque de
financement mais par manque de candidats
cette médurerie de ressources humaines
concerne cette pénurie de ressources
humaines concerne tous les services
hospitaliers puisque au plan national
30% des postes de praticiens
hospitaliers et 6% des postes infirmiers
vous l'avez souligné sont vacances
nous travaillons en démarche forte pour
favoriser l'attractivité des métiers du
système de santé c'est d'ailleurs l'un
des axes majeurs du Conseil national de
la refondation en santé que j'ai lancé
au Mans avec le ministre de la santé et
de la prévention hier mais nous
apportons aussi des solutions de court
terme c'était tout l'objet des mesures
de la mission flash de cet été avec la
possibilité dans chaque territoire de
mobiliser les solutions réunies dans une
boîte à outils ont ainsi la possibilité
de le faire en rentrant d'abord cette
recommandation simple à nos concitoyens
n'allez pas directement aux urgences
mais appelez d'abord le 15 si votre
médecin traitant n'est pas disponible en
ayant plus de professionnels de santé
disponibles avec des incitations dans
les cabinets de ville où les médecins
qui ont pris qui ont pris des patients
adressés par le 15 pouvaient bénéficier
d'une majoration de consultations de 15
euros à l'hôpital en reconnaissant les
contraintes de travail de nuit par le
doublement des majorations pour les
personnels soignants et une
revalorisation de 50% des gardes pour
les médecins nous évaluons actuellement
les résultats de chacune de ces
recommandations et pour maintenir de
façon durable toutes les solutions qui
auront fait leurs preuves
merci même la ministre la parole est à
Madame Raymond de penser pour le groupe
écologiste socialiste territoire et
solidarité pardon merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre depuis la
présentation de votre mission flash le
moral des soignants continue de baisser
selon l'enquête au doxa un quart des
soignants travaille plus de 45 heures
par semaine un quart pense est en
mauvaise santé à cause du travail et les
soignants sont deux fois plus nombreux à
se voir prescrire un arrêt de travail
pour stress que le reste de la
population active condition de travail
dégradées manque de personnel et de lit
le 30 août à Strasbourg 50 patients se
trouvaient aux urgences pour seulement
30 places 50% des lits d'hospitalisation
d'urgence était fermée par manque de
personnel 26 personnes sont restées plus
de 12 heures sur un brancard à attendre
et un homme âgé de 81 ans a attendu plus
de 22 heures jusqu'à y mourir sur son
Bran
ce drame a eu lieu malgré la politique
de régulation que vous avez mise en
place et qui aboutit à des grèves comme
au CHU de Bordeaux où le personnel
souligne avec le problème n'est pas tant
le flux de patients et les soignants qui
manquent dans son rapport d'évaluation
de la mission flash le syndicat SAMU
urgence indiquait clairement que la
non-dispedibilité de Lead aval des
services d'urgence reste le problème
principal de dysfonctionnement en
conséquence il faut ouvrir des di le
problème des urgences n'est pas
principalement un problème de régulation
mais de moyens d'attractivité des
métiers à cet égard le PLFSS 2023 se
montre malgré l'annonce de la fin des
économies demandées toujours
insuffisants la Fédération hospitalière
de France estime que l'augmentation de
l'ondamment hospitalier est dès à
présent insuffisante pour absorber
l'inflation le Ségur la revalorisation
du point d'indice et le paiement des
heures supplémentaires elle ne permettra
aucune embauche supplémentaire alors
qu'il est d'augmenter le ratio de
soignants par patient ma question est
donc contenue de l'impact mécanique de
ces coups que je viens d'évoquer de la
vie de la FHF envisagez-vous de
réajuster à la hausse longue dame pour
répondre enfin aux cons aux causes
structurelles des difficultés de
l'hôpital
je vais rappeler à tout le monde de bien
vouloir respecter son temps même à 5
secondes parce que multiplier par tout
le monde ça fait quand même beaucoup à
la fin merci beaucoup madame la ministre
vous avez la parole
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
l'objectif national des dépenses
d'assurance maladie ont dames vient
apporter des finances en plus en
apportant une progression par rapport au
financement de l'année précédente pour
long dame 2023 aucune mesure d'économie
ne repose sur l'hôpital au contraire les
dépenses relatives aux établissements
sont en hausse de plus 4,1% dans le long
terme de 2023 soit 4 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires par rapport au budget de
l'année 2022 nous maintiendrons une
attention particulière dans les
prochaines années sur l'ONDAM
établissement pour porter des réformes
d'organisation et une ambition
d'excellence mais également pour
garantir l'attractivité des métiers ce
niveau d'Honda lui permettra aussi de
faire face à l'augmentation de
l'inflation sur cette période avec un
soutien financier aux professionnels de
santé et un soutien aux établissements
pour faire face à l'augmentation des
charges hors rémunération des personnels
par ailleurs pour soutenir les hôpitaux
et ses personnels nous lançons dans le
cadre d'une Conseil national de la
réfondation en santé un chantier pour me
vivre à l'hôpital qui aura aborder les
sujets des conditions de travail l'enjeu
est de permettre aux soignants
actuellement en exercice de retrouver le
sens de leur engagement pour qu'il reste
en poste et que les jeunes aient envie
de rejoindre les établissements de santé
enfin le niveau de l'ONDA en 2023 et
bien supérieur à celui que nous pouvions
connaître précédemment l'ONDAM en 2016
était ainsi à 1,8% et l'ONDA en 2017 à
2,2 avec un nom d'âme 2023 à 3,7 hors
dépenses de crise nous investissons donc
massivement dans notre système de santé
merci beaucoup la parole est à Madame
Étienne pomirol pour le groupe
socialiste écoulé écologiste et
républicain
si ça vous dérange pas parce que je
m'appelle Mylène
franchement je crois que je suis un tout
petit peu fatiguée parce que vraiment je
n'oublie pas votre prénom Emilienne
Poumirol merci madame la Présidente la
ministre mes chers collègues
beaucoup d'annonces beaucoup de
consultations encore celle du CNR et en
fait pas beaucoup de mesures
structurelles pour répondre à la crise
de l'accès aux soins en France et en
particulier sur le problème des déserts
en santé et pourtant l'organisation
territoriale des soins représente un
enjeu majeur pour répondre aux besoins
de santé de notre population avec une
nécessaire meilleure articulation des
acteurs de ville et des acteurs
hospitaliers la question cruciale de
l'engagement de l'engorgement pardon des
services hospitaliers et connu depuis
longtemps puisqu'on considère et tout le
monde s'accorde à le dire qu'au moins de
30% des patients qui arrivent à
l'hôpital aurait pu être évité s'il y
avait eu une régulation préalable
effectivement fait or depuis 2002 et la
décision du ministre de Jean-François
Mattei de supprimer l'obligation de
garde des médecins libéraux on observe
une érosion permanente de cette
permanence des soins le volontariat
n'est plus suffisant pour répondre à la
demande de permanence des soins sur le
territoire et particulièrement avéré
dans les déserts médicaux et ma collègue
Laurent sur le Cohen l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure à Caen une PDSA obligatoire pour
tous les médecins et pas simplement les
médecins généralistes
au regard des situations votre
gouvernement a mis en place cet été
différente dispositifs suite à une
mission flash une énième mission
demandée au professeur Braun comme si
l'on découvrait j'allais dire le
problème de notre hôpital face à des
problèmes structurels vous répondez
encore et toujours par des mesures
prises dans l'urgence pour ne pas dire
dans la précipitation et pour des
objectifs à court terme ma question va
se centraliser sur un seul point petit
focus sur le problème des mesures qui
ont proposé une majoration pour les
soins non programmés pour les actes
effectués par les médecins généralistes
après régulation vous l'avez évoqué tout
à l'heure 15 euros supplémentaires pour
eux dans ce type de consultation
malheureusement le cadre cette
régulation inclut celle effectué par SOS
médecins mais si elles effectuées par
les CPTs ne paraissent pas l'être ce qui
paraît incompréhensible et c'est une
notion que nous a donné mG France merci
chers collègues merci même la ministre
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
nous avons souhaité encourager les
médecins libéraux à prendre leur part à
la prise en charge des soins non
programmés cet été pour cela nous avons
suivi la recommandation de la mission
flash sur les urgences et soins non
programmées de créer une majoration en
attribuant à titre dérogatoire et
temporaire un supplément de 15 euros
pour tout acte effectué par un médecin
libéral à la demande de la régulation du
SAMU SAS pour un patient qui ne fait pas
partie de sa patientèle habituelle cette
majoration n'a été utilisée que par 4%
des généralistes libéraux pour un total
d'environ 50000 actes beaucoup de
médecins généralistes nous ont cependant
signalé qu'il prenait en charge des
soins non programmés sans que ce signe
ne soit nécessairement orienté par le
SAMU ou les SAS nous sommes en train
d'analyser ces données pour voir quel
serait le meilleur schéma de financement
des soins non programmés je tiens à
souligner la mobilisation des médecins
libéraux qui se sont engagés cet été
dans beaucoup de territoires des
organisations ont été montées par des
libéraux pour permettre la prise en
charge des soins non programmés de
manière temporaire pour soutenir le
système hospitalier très attention cet
été et cela a très bien fonctionné
[Musique]
pour tous se fait sentir dans son bilan
de l'année 2021 lors des médecins
disaient que le taux de participation
global des médecins généralistes à la
permanence des soins ambulatoires et
malheureusement reparti à la baisse 36%
des territoires de permanence de soins
sont couverts par mois de 10 médecins
volontaires et 20% des territoires de
ces permanences sont couverts par moins
de 5 médecins volontaires c'est grave
pas loin de chez moi nos amis belges ont
mis en place une permanence de médecine
générale sur le même site que leur
accueil d'urgence avec un accès unique
et un triage commun ainsi les urgences
traitent des urgences et les médecins
généralistes traitent de ce qui est de
leur compétences le suivi médical face à
l'urgence chacun doit prendre sa charge
la méthode madame la ministre pourrait
être bénéfique puisque la santé des
Français en dépend et donc notre
question est la suivante le gouvernement
tant il soutenir l'ouverture de ce type
d'unité dont les équipes se
reconstituées de médecins généralistes
volontaires voire de réinstaurer
l'obligation de garde des médecins
généralistes pour assurer l'efficience
de ces structures je vous remercie
madame la ministre
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Sénateur nous avons assurément nous
inspirer de bonnes pratiques mises en
œuvre dans nos pays voisins et là on
prend en l'occurrence de la Belgique
c'est certain les services des urgences
sont en Wallonie reposent souvent sur un
modèle d'accueil par une infirmière dont
les fonctions sont assez proches de
l'infirmier organisateur de l'accueil
déployés également en France par
ailleurs la régulation des appels
d'urgence en Belgique ne comprend pas de
régulation médicale comme en France or
je crois que sur ce point nous devons
garder la plus-value du système français
qui associe des opérateurs dédiés les
assistants de régulation médicale et la
présence de médecins dans les centres de
régulation malheureusement nos voisins
belges sont confrontés au même problème
que nous avec les mêmes difficultés à
recruter dans les hôpitaux et des taux
d'absentéisme élevés le gouvernement
fédéral a adopté des mesures au mois de
juillet 2022 destinées à contrer le
manque de personnels soignants dans les
hôpitaux en favorisant la reprise
d'activité de soignants retraités de
même le ministre fédéral des Affaires
sociales et de la santé publique de
Belgique a annoncé au mois de juin
visant à réformer l'organisation de la
médecine générale en Belgique partant du
constat qu'il y avait un nombre
insuffisant de médecins généralistes en
Belgique et qu'il fallait mais améliorer
l'accessibilité aux patients vous le
voyez nos voisins européens connaissent
les mêmes difficultés que nous ce n'est
pas propre à la France mais c'est en
recherchant les bonnes initiatives dans
nos territoires ou chez nos voisins que
nous pourrons construire ensemble des
solutions durables et pour la
problématique de la permanence des soins
nous savons et nous sommes au moment où
nous allons entretenir et ouvrir la
convention collective avec les médecins
pouvoir engager les sujets sur la
responsabilité collective c'est bien
ensemble que nous trouverons les
solutions à ces problèmes
merci la parole est à Madame Florence la
Sarrade pour le groupe les républicains
notre système de santé connaît de fortes
tensions dans un contexte de démographie
médicale tendu qui impacte notamment les
services d'urgence ma question porte sur
la crise des urgences en Gironde sur le
territoire suggérant les urgences
vitales dépendent d'une seule équipe
d'urgence celles et d'urgence et du SMUR
du centre hospitalier de Langon pendant
toute la période estivale ce service a
assuré ses missions 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 sans fermer ses portes une
fois de plus le service d'urgence a tenu
grâce aux professionnels de santé malgré
les conditions d'exercices très
difficiles
cet investissement est lié à une équipe
d'urgence fidèle à l'esprit hospitalier
investit dans le système depuis
plusieurs années les internes du service
ils sont encadrés dans leurs
apprentissages le stage aux urgences de
Langon et
plébiscité par les internes de Gironde
pour motiver les jeunes internes les
jeunes urgentistes à intégrer cette
hôpital de périphérie un plan
d'accompagnement hospitalier en effet
été élaboré l'objectif et de leur faire
découvrir cette médecine polyvalente
exigeante et difficile sur un vaste
territoire mais riche et intéressante en
étant portées par une solidarité
d'équipe or ces jeunes spécialistes de
la médecine d'urgence qui ont pourtant
apprécié de venir travailler à Langon se
tourne ensuite vers les centres
hospitaliers voisins qui proposent des
contrats très lucratifs sur le long
terme monsieur le ministre
pardon madame la ministre la situation
du service d'urgence de l'hôpital de
Langon n'est pas un cas isolé il ne
faudrait pas en arriver à la situation
des urgences d'Arès sur le Bassin
d'Arcachon qui viennent de fermer leurs
portes pour un mois faute de médecin
aussi madame la ministre envisagez-vous
une valorisation des gardes des
urgentistes à la hauteur de l'engagement
fourni et de leur activité à très haute
responsabilité afin de maintenir et de
consolider les services d'urgence dans
les territoires périphériques quels sont
vos propositions pour lutter contre le
retour massif à l'intérieur dont le coût
est prohibitif
merci madame la ministre
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
comme vous l'indiquez le service des
urgences de Langon a continué à assurer
ses missions 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours
sur 7 sans fermer ses portes il faut
d'abord saluer l'engagement des
soignants de cet établissement pour
faire le faire fonctionner concernant le
sujet que vous évoquez de concurrence
des rémunérations la RS nouvelle
Aquitaine analysé la situation notre
amant après avoir pris connaissance des
départs vers l'hôpital de Marmande il
ressort que cet hôpital ne pratique pas
des conditions statutaires ou de
rémunération dérogatoire à la
réglementation j'en profite aussi pour
souligner le rôle remarquable du centre
hospitalier de SUD Gironde cet été pour
venir en appui des évacuations des
populations dans le cadre des incendies
massifs du département le sujet de la
rémunération et de la valorisation des
gardes et bien sûr un des facteurs de
reconnaissance à ce titre les
recommandations de la mission flash sur
les urgences et les soins programmés ont
reconnu pour la première fois la
pénibilité du travail de nuit est mis en
place pour trois mois un doublement des
indemnités de suggestions pour la nuit
pour les personnels paramédicaux et une
majoration de 10% applicable au
personnel médicaux de manière plus
globale le ministre de la santé et de la
prévention a annoncé hier lors du
lancement du CNR de la en santé
l'ouverture d'un chantier au niveau
national pour mieux vivre à l'hôpital
qui aura vocation à aborder ces sujets
des conditions de travail créons les
conditions pour que les soignants
actuellement en exercice retrouvent le
sens de leur engagement pour que les
jeunes se sentent accueillis dès la
première heure de leurs études en santé
dès le premier jour de leur stage qu'ils
aient envie de rejoindre les
établissements de santé et que les plus
expérimentés et envie d'y rester enfin
s'agissant de la lutte contre les
dérives de l'intérim c'est un sujet
majeur face à de telles pratiques le
risque est grand de fissurer
profondément l'esprit d'équipe dans nos
hôpitaux la députée Stéphanie apportée
par la loi l'encadrement des
rémunérations il est temps de la mettre
en application le ministre de la Santé a
annoncé un calendrier à compter de
printemps 2023 il ne sera plus possible
de payer démesurément en intérimaire
d'ici cette échéance les situations à
risque devons être identifiées dans les
territoires avec le concours des ARS et
parce que les hôpitaux aussi nous le
demandent il ne sera plus possible à la
sortie de sa formation de soignants de
démarrer sur l'exercice professionnel
par de l'intérim c'est une des mesures
qui est inscrite dans le pvss pour 2023
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Luc Fichet
pour le groupe socialiste républicain
le pire a été évité grâce à
l'investissement exceptionnel dans notre
mais notre système de santé est à bout
de souffle les personnels n'ont pas
d'espoir d'amélioration de leurs
conditions de travail il est à craindre
que l'hémorragie de démission à
l'hôpital continue ce qui entraînerait
encore des fermetures de lit et de
services à Morlaix par exemple entre
arrêt de travail et poste non pourvu ce
sont les gardes et les remplacements qui
sont difficiles et cela malgré la sur
majoration des heures supplémentaires en
oncologie on fait des chimiothérapie
dans les couloirs les services sont
embolisés les patients demeure dans le
service des urgences même le retour à
domicile est compromis face au manque
d'ambulanciers malgré cela la RS
Bretagne déclare le 21 septembre dernier
dans un grand quotidien que l'été c'est
globalement bien passé quel mépris quel
déni de la réalité 6 millions de
Français n'ont pas accès à un médecin
traitant 15000 personnes dans le
Finistère n'ont pas de médecins
référents l'hôpital absente donc de plus
en plus des soins non programmés et une
annonce une baisse des médecins
généralistes jusqu'en 2030 le système de
santé dans son ensemble est à revoir
depuis la loi Hôpital Patient sont tes
territoires nous alertons sans cesse sur
la disparition de l'offre de soins dans
les territoires nous proposons en vain
des solutions qui nécessairement devront
être incitives pour une offre de son
hospitalier et de médecine de ville au
plus près des besoins réels il ne doit
plus y avoir de place pour les
mercenaires de la médecine comme les
appeler Madame butin qui mettent à mal
les budgets des petits hôpitaux du fait
de leur exigence financière exorbitante
madame la ministre il y a urgence quelle
décision pensez-vous prendre
immédiatement pour les Françaises et les
Français qui n'ont plus accès aux soins
médicaux
si madame la ministre
madame la Présidente Monsieur
tout d'abord vous dire que si le
ministère d'angélonneur d'avoir la
charge le ministère de l'organisation
territoriale et des professions de santé
c'est bien parce que le Président de la
République et la première ministre ont
pris conscience comme tous ici après ces
quatre mois de campagne qu'il y avait
urgence à agir il y a urgence à agir
pourquoi parce que les décisions prises
lors du dernier quinquennat sont des
mesures du temps long et qu'elle ne
produisent pas encore l'effet escompté
il y a urgence à agir pourquoi parce
qu'après deux ans de crise sanitaire
nous avons des personnels soignants qui
sont épuisés il y a urgence à agir
pourquoi parce que nous vivons nous
vivons un phénomène sociétal où les
nouveaux entrants sur le marché du
travail les nouveaux médecins ne
souhaitent plus travailler comme les
médecins d'avant un médecin qui part en
retraite aujourd'hui doit être remplacé
par trois médecins
non je pense pas raconter de conneries
madame je suis désolé mais
donc nous sommes nous sommes vraiment
sur une situation où l'urgence agir elle
est là nous travaillons depuis le mois
de juillet avec les collectivités
territoriales avec les professionnels de
santé le CNR n'est pas un énième
diagnostic nous proposons déjà dans le
PLFSS des mesures je le dis il y a
urgence à travailler ensemble pour sur
les territoires permettre à nos
personnels de trouver de permettre à de
répondre aux besoins de soins de nos
concitoyens les médecins un médecin
formé un médecin c'est 10 ans le numerus
clausus a été supprimé il nous faut donc
dix ans pour former des nouveaux
médecins donc nous allons avec les
professionnels avec l'évolution des
formations nous avons ouvert tous les
sujets laissez-nous encore quelques mois
pour pouvoir répondre à ces sujets mais
nous c'est ensemble c'est pas le
ministère de la Santé tout seul qui
dénondra des mesures qui s'appliqueront
sur les territoires elles devront
s'adapter à chaque territoire
merci Monsieur fichier vous avez 19
secondes la ministre merci pour votre
réponse pensez aux élus locaux qui sont
tous les jours sollicités face à des
administrés qui n'ont pas de réponse sur
la question depuis 10 ans que je
m'occupe de ces sujets je peux vous dire
que les réponses sont toujours les mêmes
des augmentations des stages mais jamais
de vrais réponses dans les territoires
ou des administrés non plus aujourd'hui
de médecins et ça c'est extrêmement
grave il y a urgence à porter de vraies
réponses immédiatement je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Sol pour
le groupe les républicains
madame la Présidente et madame la
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai mal
j'ai mal j'ai mal j'ai 90 ans j'ai mal
j'attends au fond d'un couloir depuis 24
heures sur un brancard inconfortable que
l'on vienne me prendre en charge j'ai
mal mal de savoir que ma grand-mère mon
père ma femme ou mon enfant souffre et
d'attendre interminablement des
nouvelles les concernant j'ai mal de ne
pas pouvoir gérer la flux de patients
pouvant générer une perte de chance mal
de voir mon serment d'Hippocrate bafoué
par le poids des normes de la charge
administrative et du manque de moyens
humains comme vous le savez madame la
ministre nos services d'accueil des
urgences véritable vitrines des
établissements sont en souffrance et
c'est toute une chaîne d'homme et de
femmes qui empathissent alors que
l'accueil la qualité et la sécurité de
la prise en charge devrait naturellement
s'imposer à tous cependant nous ne
voyons pas dans nos territoires
d'amélioration significative je le
regrette et la prévision démographique
en matière de vieillissement le rassure
pas sur les flux à prendre en charge
dans un contexte de une certification
médicale de médecine de ville essoufflée
et de dégradation des conditions de
travail cet été le président de Sam
urgence France nous a rappelé que
c'était aussi le Smur et le Centre 15
qui était en grande difficulté de
fonctionnement le nombre de prises en
charge aux urgences à doubler en 20 ans
passant de 10 à 20 millions
j'interrogeais ici même madame Busin en
2018 sur l'ensemble de ses
préoccupations mais aujourd'hui encore
les mêmes problèmes remontent non
seulement du terrain mais aussi des
enquêtes le SAMU urgence France pointe
est en effet récemment l'insuffisance de
lidaval et de SSR la fermeture de
certains services d'urgence où les
inquiétants départs en masse de nos
soignants alors madame la ministre
qu'allez-vous faire pour éviter la fuite
de nos personnels personnels qui sont
épuisés depuis la crise sanitaire
pendant laquelle ils ont tout donné
qu'allez-vous faire pour lutter contre
la désertification médicale qui majorent
langage l'engorgement aux urgences
qu'allez-vous faire pour mettre enfin en
adéquation les rémunérations avec un
niveau de formation et les diplômes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur sénateur
nous avons tous mal à notre système de
santé c'est bien pour ça que nous y
travaillons tous et que nous allons
devoir y travailler tous ensemble tout
d'abord dans le cadre du CNR en santé je
l'ai déjà dit le groupe de travail mieux
vivre à l'hôpital c'est bien comment
accompagner nos personnels soignants
accompagner l'attractivité des métiers
pour redonner du sens deux ans de crise
sanitaires ont fini j'allais dire je le
dire d'accélérer le process d'un système
de santé qui ne va pas qui ne va pas
bien maintenant vous l'avez dit
vous-même un médecin je le redis un
médecin c'est 10 ans nous avons supprimé
le numéro de clausus il y a maintenant
deux ans il est effectif il faut 10 ans
pour former un médecin en attendant que
faisons-nous pour répondre aux besoins
de santé de nos concitoyens il nous faut
dégager du temps médical c'est le sens
des mesures qui sont prises notamment
avec le déploiement des assistants
médicaux il nous faut améliorer les
processus de coopération entre tous les
professionnels c'est bien ce qui est
fait notamment dans le cadre des CPTs il
nous faut enfin
en chantier tous les métiers de la santé
et les rendre attractifs c'est le sens
du chantier que nous allons ouvrir avec
mes collègues sur les formations les
formations initiales mais aussi les
formations continues de toutes les
professions et non pas uniquement de
celles des médecins généralistes nous le
savons tous notre système de santé ne va
pas bien il ne va pas bien uniquement
depuis 2022 c'est la conséquence je peux
être d'une faillite collective depuis
des années maintenant il nous faut nous
mettre tous ensemble les élus et c'est
bien pour ça que mon ministère porte le
nom d'organisation territoriale et c'est
bien avec les élus avec les
professionnels avec les usagers que nous
allons pouvoir répondre aux solutions en
organisant de façon territoriale et
apporter des réponses territoire par
territoire
merci la parole est à Monsieur Bruno
Belin pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues madame la
ministre par votre expérience et votre
engagement vous savez la réalité des
souffrances des désespérances dans nos
urgences des attentes aussi des peines
vous savez aussi la réalité des lits
fermés rien que dans l'hôpital Poitiers
dans le département je suis élu 271 lit
fermé cet été et d'ailleurs à un moment
donné il faudra que vous nous disiez la
réalité du nombre de lits fermés depuis
quelques années vous savez la
désespérance aussi des territoires qui
se sentent abandonnés tous ces hôpitaux
de proximité sur les territoires où on a
l'impression que les politiques de santé
sont désertées dans le département où je
suis élu pardon de prendre des exemples
que je connais le moins mal à l'oudun ou
à Montmorillon il y a plus de services
d'urgence alors vous savez la différence
entre urgence ou soit non programmée est
compliquée quand vous quelqu'un qui
vient effectivement en souffrance un
dimanche il attend une réponse et bien
dans ces territoires là il n'y en a pas
et on est face à
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
l'agence régionale de santé de
nouvelle-aquitaine qui tient des
réunions territoriales hebdomadaires
pour assurer un suivi resserrer les
tensions hospitalières en liant avec la
préfecture du CHU de Poitiers face aux
tensions hospitalière rencontrée par le
CHU engendre une diminution des
effectifs de l'équipe territoriale
d'urgence qui fonctionne sur les quatre
sites je tiens à souligner que le chute
Poitiers tout particulièrement utilisé
pour la recherche des professionnels de
santé les urgences de Loudun et de
Montmorillon vous avez cité font l'objet
d'un suivi d'une vigilance toute
particulière pour limiter au maximum les
gares de non-couverte et organiser un
accès régulier des patients dans les
deux sites l'accueil des patients est
organisé de la manière suivante quand
les gardes ne peuvent être couvertes la
régulation est assurée par le 15 et la
population est informée de la nécessité
de ne pas se rendre aux urgences mais
d'appeler le 15 sur site si une personne
se présente un accueil est organisée par
une infirmière qui sollicite le 15 pour
déterminer la réorientation à effectuer
orientation vers Poitiers ou une autre
structure hospitalière renvoie vers le
médecin traitant ou programmation d'une
consultation le lendemain
[Musique]
pour les solutions qui fonctionnent
aussi celles qui ne fonctionnent pas et
comprendre pourquoi elles ne
fonctionnent pas merci madame la
ministre monsieur Belin vous avez 40
secondes
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre ma chère consœur faites de ces
hôpitaux de proximité
une chance et une priorité ils ont le
ressenti d'être victimes d'un délestage
or c'est un non sens c'est un non-stance
d'abord vous-même vous l'avez dit sans
rien orientés vers voilà tel CHU c'est
un non-sens parce que c'est un non-sens
écologique on est dans une stratégie bas
carbone et on met les gens sur les
routes ça bloque des pompiers c'est un
non-sens aussi territorial parce qu'on a
des coquilles vies dans des hôpitaux de
proximité et puis c'est un non-sens
surtout en termes de santé parce que de
la perte de temps c'est de la perte de
chance merci Madame la présente
madame la ministre vous vous avez vous
avez une minute et Monsieur Belin aura
une minute également il n'y a pas de
souci c'est prévu
ça doit être
ça doit être ça doit être ça ça doit
être les madame
monsieur le sénateur
l'enjeu des hôpitaux de proximité des
hôpitaux périphériques il est pour moi
essentiels je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure l'enjeu des formations et de
l'évolution des formations elle est
primordiale on va y arriver si nous
pouvons aussi faire en sorte que nos
internes qui se forment ne fassent pas
tout leur stage dans les CHU qu'il
puisse aller faire leur stage dans les
hôpitaux périphériques et dans les
hôpitaux de proximité c'est ce sur quoi
nous sommes en train de travailler je
n'ai pas le voilà c'est pas facile de
tout vous expliquer ce chantier il est
ouvert mettons les internes devant les
dans les hôpitaux de proximité et dans
les hôpitaux de périphérie et que un bon
nombre d'entre eux pourront après s'y
installer et on évitera ce genre
d'accueil et ce genre de situation
si Monsieur Belin vous avez une minute
chiche madame la ministre alors godet je
vous attends dans les territoires ruraux
dont vous venez de parler parce que vous
verrez si moi je veux bien qu'on fasse
des stages il faut que encore qu'il y
ait des maîtres de stage faut encore
qu'il y ait des médecins pour former on
va pas apprendre à lire League donc je
vous attends dans les meilleurs délais
sur les territoires ruraux dans ces
hôpitaux de proximité pour que vous
veniez voir la réalité merci Madame
présidente merci la parole est à Madame
Sylviane Noël pour le groupe les
républicains
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues avec plus de 20
millions de passages par an les urgences
de nos hôpitaux sont engorgées au plus
haut point confrontés à un double effet
ciseau d'une part la pénurie de
soignants plus grave que jamais et une
forte augmentation du recours aux
urgences pour nos compatriotes en effet
pour des millions de Français le recours
aux urgences est une absolue nécessité
faute de pouvoir bénéficier des services
d'un médecin traitant la médecine de
ville ne semble plus aujourd'hui en
capacité de remplir de façon efficiente
son rôle de soins de premier recours
souffrant d'un maillage déséquilibré et
incomplet de l'ensemble du territoire
face à cette situation préoccupante
j'aurais souhaité vous entendre sur
d'autres propositions d'une part une
participation plus large des médecins
libéraux à la permanence des soins via
les CPTs puisque cette permanence repose
aujourd'hui essentiellement sur les
hôpitaux s'agissant des weekends et des
jours fériés d'autre part une réforme de
la libre installation des médecins
généralistes fait-elle partie des pistes
envisagées par le gouvernement pour
tenter de lutter contre les déserts
médicaux et remédier à l'inégalité
position des médecins généralistes je
vous remercie merci madame la ministre
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
répondre à vos deux points tout d'abord
sur la permanence des soins nous devons
améliorer la situation de la permanence
des soins ça a déjà été dit plusieurs
fois la permanence des soins est une
mission de service public et elle doit
être assurée partout sur le territoire
nous souhaitons placer les médecins en
situation de responsabilité collective
sur la question de la permanence des
soins pour ça il y a deux solutions soit
les professionnels de santé s'organisent
par eux-mêmes et remplissent entre le
tableau de garde selon les contraintes
là où il y a une CPTs cela peut être le
bon échelon pour organiser cette
permanence soit il y a défaut de
couverture et l'État devra prévoir une
organisation pour assurer aux françaises
et aux Français un accès à des soins non
programmés en soirée le week-end le code
de la santé publique prévoit déjà la
possibilité de réquisitionner des
médecins en cas de défaillance sur la
libre installation la libre installation
beaucoup de monde à ce qu'on revienne
dessus on nous répète par exemple qu'on
contraint bien les enseignants à aller
partout sur le territoire d'une part je
trouve que cette comparaison ne
fonctionne pas et d'autres je ne crois
pas à l'efficacité de l'obligation notre
objectif c'est d'inciter plus fortement
et même de convaincre nos territoires
sous dotés méritent des médecins qui s'y
installent volontairement et qui s'y
investissent oui nous devons travailler
à d'autres modalités modalités
d'installation des médecins sur le
territoire nous y travaillons d'ailleurs
dans le projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale en prévoyant un
nouveau dispositif simplifié en matière
d'aide à l'installation et concerté dans
le cadre d'un comité local
d'associations les représentants des
élus locaux les professionnels de santé
et les administrations
merci Madame Noël vous avez 53 secondes
merci Madame la miss pour vos réponses
j'aimerais aborder à présent le la
seconde partie de mon intervention qui
concerne la pénurie de soignants les
causes sont diverses nombreuses et
anciennes et les réponses à cette
problématique sont tout aussi complexes
et multiples il met cependant impossible
de ne pas profiter de ce temps de parole
pour à nouveau vous sensibiliser sur la
réintégration des milliers de soignants
et pompiers suspendus ou interdits
d'exercices depuis plus d'un an
maintenant dans notre pays cette
situation n'est plus tenable la
quasi-totalité des pays ont abandonné
cette mesure vous laissez même
aujourd'hui aux soignants la libre choix
de recourir aux nouveaux vaccins contre
la covid-19 dans ces circonstances le
maintien de cette mesure est
incompréhensible et relève davantage de
la punition et de l'obstination que de
la justification sanitaire notre système
de santé est à l'agonie nous ne pouvons
plus nous passer du moindre soignant ma
question est simple quand envisagez-vous
de lever cette mesure qui engendre un
peu plus de dysfonctionnement et
d'engorgement merci même
vous souhaitez répondre
sinon normalement une réplique ça
concerne la question au départ en fait
c'est pas de séparer la question en deux
voilà même la ministre vous avez une
mine merci madame la présidente Madame
la signatrice je veux dire à celles et
ceux qui pensent que c'est une réponse
miracle pour répondre aux problèmes
d'effectif de l'hôpital qu'il se trompe
il faut être clair cela concerne
quelques centaines de personnes sur plus
de 300 000 soignants qui ont donc refusé
de se protéger pour protéger les autres
ce que je préfère retenir c'est le sens
citoyen et l'éthique des professionnels
de santé qui sont au contact des
Français les plus fragiles il faut
rendre hommage à tous les professionnels
mobilisés qui ont accompli leurs devoirs
avec courage les avis du conseil
scientifique et de la Haute Autorité de
son santé ont été rendues et ils sont
favorables au maintien de l'obligation
de vaccination contre la covid-19 des
personnels exerçant dans les
établissements de santé et
médico-sociaux nous avons toujours géré
cette crise en nous basant sur les
recommandations des scientifiques et ce
n'est pas aujourd'hui que cela va
changer
si ma Noël vous avez une minute pour
répondre
rassurez-vous je reposerai pas une
troisième question madame Lise je me
désoles simplement de cette obscination
qui vraiment finit par nous conduire
dans le mur il faut quand même savoir
qu'il y a aujourd'hui aussi des
étudiants en médecine qui sont suspendus
demain vous vous
permettez pas d'aborder dignement les
enjeux de l'hôpital en terme d'effectif
en maintenant cette mesure je vous donne
un exemple dans mon dans mon département
de la Haute-Savoie la plupart des
soignants partent en Suisse parce que
cette obligation vaccinale elle a été
levée et ça fait encore un argument de
plus pour ses soignants pour partir donc
moi franchement il faut qu'on m'explique
qu'elle est aujourd'hui le sens du
maintien de cette mesure
merci la parole est à Monsieur Laurent
saumon pour le groupe les républicains
madame la présidente madame la ministre
la situation notre système de santé avec
les fermetures de lit et de celle des
urgences en particulier n'ont jamais été
aussi préoccupante en haute France
notamment de raison majeures des
différents constats rapports mission
flash tout d'abord l'attractivité des
carrières médicales hospitalières en
dépit de la réforme du statut unique en
effet l'équité de temps et de
rémunération au sein d'un même service
n'est toujours pas une réalité
demi-journée de travail tant continue
seuil du statut unique plage additionnel
activité mixte et activités libérale
intra-hospitalière recours à l'intérim
autant d'occasions pour un même service
de faire cohabiter des ruminations des
rémunérations disparates et d'aggraver
les tensions c'est le sentiment
d'appartenance à une équipe médicale
solidaire qui peut faire accepter les
difficultés inhérentes à la profession
en haut de France les effectifs partent
vers la Belgique ou le Luxembourg que
comptez-vous mettre en place pour
redonner ce sens à ses professionnels
ensuite la deuxième c'est la gestion des
causes majeures des la gestion des flux
des urgences question elle a pénibilité
et au sens de l'activité comment le
gouvernement permet de décloisonnement
entre la médecine de ville et l'hôpital
général avec l'objectif de fluidifier le
parcours des soins des Français et de
désengorger les urgences à côté des
grands CHU les hôpitaux de proximité
comme ça a été dit la médecine de lui
doivent être organisés pour assurer le
même service à une patientèle de
l'urgence en milieu rural ou pour des
populations souvent sans ressources ce
qui est possible aux urgences comme le
tiers payant doit être vrai et facilité
en première ligne quel dispositif
d'implantation des praticiens en ville
mettaient prévoyez vous en l'état actuel
les personnels qui ont quitté le secteur
de la santé ne sont pas prêts d'y
revenir allons-nous pouvoir arrêter
l'hémorragie en réactivant la médecine
de ville avec le retour et les soutiens
aux gardes et des soutiens aux
installations obligatoires ou pas en
ville y compris pour les EHPAD parce que
les services d'urgence en restreignant
leur accès faute de personnel c'est en
tout cas le cas dans la Somme
merci madame la ministre
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Sénateur la réforme du statut unique
poursuivait bien l'objectif que vous
décrivez pour amener davantage de
cohésion au sein d'un même service pour
autant les conditions d'exercice et les
suggestions demeurent hétérogènes et il
est nécessaire de pouvoir reconnaître
les situations individuelles de même le
recours à des professionnels de santé
libéraux a pour objectif de renforcer
des équipes qui sont confrontées à de
fortes difficultés de recrutement les
professionnels de santé libéraux qui
sont intervenus dans les établissements
ont conservé les charges de leur cabinet
en parallèle et de leur activité
hospitalière pour favoriser leur
engagement il était justifié de pouvoir
les indemniser de manière appropriée
concernant l'intérêt nous avons tracé un
chemin nous allons appliquer la loi
risque d'ici le printemps 2023
l'encadrement des rémunérations de même
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure il ne
sera plus possible à la sortie de sa
formation de soignants de démarrer son
exercice professionnel par de l'intérim
c'est une mesure du PLFSS pour 2023
concernant votre deuxième question vous
avez raison une partie du flux des
urgences peut être prise en charge si on
fluidifie la réponse aux soins non
programmés en ville c'est l'objet du
service d'accès aux soins qui se
déploient progressivement sur le
territoire national nous devons
accélérer sa mise en place il a vocation
à pouvoir aider les citoyens à
s'orienter dans notre système de santé
le patient pourra ainsi bénéficier d'une
orientation vers la réponse la plus
adaptée à son besoin de santé pour
compléter ce schéma nous devions mieux
partager la réponse aux soins non
programmés entre l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé c'est la logique
des transferts de compétences les ordres
professionnels sont en train de
travailler à ces sujets et doivent nous
faire très vite des propositions ces
collectivement avec les médecins les
infirmiers les pharmaciens les
kinésithérapeutes les autres
professionnels que nous pouvons
contribuer à mieux répondre aux soins
non programmés
merci alors avant de conclure
ah oui monsieur saumon non non monsieur
saumon non non non
non non à partir de 8 secondes c'est
fini parce que 7 secondes monsieur
saumon ça va pas faire cette seconde
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît donc
avant de conclure donc je vais me
permettre de souhaiter un bon
anniversaire à Monsieur Ruquier
voilà
[Applaudissements]
voilà chers président alors pour
conclure le débat la parole est à même
la présidente Catherine de roche pour le
groupe les républicains
madame la présidente madame la ministre
ma chère collègue notre groupe les
républicains a choisi d'inscrire ce
débat sur les urgences hospitalières et
les soins non programmés à l'ouverture
de cette nouvelle session et je m'en
félicite après avoir décidé de la crème
la création d'une commission d'enquête
sur l'hôpital que j'ai rapporté au début
de cette année cela montre bien la
volonté du Sénat au-delà du travail de
la commission des affaires sociales de
ne jamais relâcher l'attention porter à
notre système de santé prenez Paul
Savary la souligné en introduction la
ville comme l'hôpital traverse une crise
profonde et les réponses doivent être
rapides comme plusieurs collègues l'ont
rappelé ce débat vient aussi après un
été que nous redoutions pour les
services d'urgence à l'hôpital ou un
risque de rupture d'accès aux soins
étaient bien avancés par de nombreux
professionnels de santé
si la situation a bien été difficile et
beaucoup pendant témoigner et a conduit
de grands établissements hospitaliers à
des mesures de régulation strictes à
l'accès de leur service l'hôpital a
néanmoins une nouvelle fois tenue une
nouvelle fois mais à quel prix ce que
nous voyons c'est une succession
ininterrompue de période de tension sur
différents secteurs hospitaliers ce que
nous voyons c'est la survenue continue
de crise dans les crises à l'été sur les
urgences hospitalières et les maternités
aujourd'hui sur les réanimations
pédiatriques en Île-de-France et ce
alors que la crise covid dont on ne
parle presque plus a toujours un impact
sensible sur l'hôpital
quelles conséquence des risques immédiat
pour la sécurité des patients dans leur
prise en charge des soins parfois
assurés sur un mode dégradé des retards
d'accès aux soins et donc des pertes de
chances mais surtout à moyen terme comme
un court terme des conséquences majeures
sur l'état de l'hôpital et la situation
des soignants
car ces crises successives ne font que
renforcer l'épuisement des équipes
appelé à se mobiliser toujours plus
elles ne font que renforcer les départs
de médecins et d'infirmiers et
fragilisent donc encore notre système
l'hôpital a tenu mais jusqu'à quand mon
intervention en conclusion va se
concentrer sur l'avenir madame la
ministre votre Ministre de tutelle aussi
l'auteur d'un rapport celui de la
mission flash sur les urgences qui
devait nous permettre selon l'expression
du moment de sauver l'été 41 mesures
dont la mise en oeuvre inégale c'est
surtout fait par voie réglementaire même
quand elle relevait du domaine de la loi
mais force est de constater à la fin de
cet été que nous peinons à trouver dans
votre feuille de route des mesures pour
prendre le relais de ces mesures
d'urgence vous l'avez un peu évoqué mais
la régulation de l'accès aux urgences
via le 15 sera-t-elle par exemple
généralisée pérennisé quel sera le tarif
durable des consultations de médecine
générale le soir et le week-end
j'entends bien que la convention
médicale qui sera négociée l'occasion de
discuter des conditions de
revalorisation de la permanence des
soins ambulatoires une négociation
longue pilotée par l'assurance maladie
mais qui échappe disons-le pour partie
au gouvernement mais surtout au
Parlement qui ne peut en prescrire le
cadrage j'attends que désormais nous
sommes aussi suspendus à de nouvelles
concertations conférence des parties
prenantes Conseil national de la
Révolution
avec un volet CNR santé encore des
discussions dont les soignants sont
fatigués pour des conclusions dont on
peine attend d'une originalité
quelconque on concerte on conserve et
pendant ce temps disons-le on n'agit pas
et puis soyons lucides pendant qu'on
concerne on ne parle pas de financement
or il y a bien enjeu financier qui n'a
pas non plus être traité madame la
ministre nous ne savons pas et nous le
Parlement le droit de savoir combien
coûté les mesures d'urgences du plan
Brown cet été alors bien sûr nous ne
regardons pas la dépense quand il s'agit
de la santé des Français répondons
souvent et alors que nous allons
examiner le mois prochain le projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale il est de notre rôle aussi en
tant que parlementaire de vérifier que
les moyens alloués à la politique de
santé sont bien en adéquation avec les
besoins alors que la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
prévoient une des rations de la
progression de lambdame inférieure à la
croissance du PIB à l'horizon 2027 il y
a la matière à s'interroger je constate
par ailleurs qu'après cet été aussi
aucune mesure relative aux urgences aux
soins non programmés ne figure européen
FS16 pour 2023 à penser donc aucune des
mesures visant à renforcer la prise en
charge en ville la structuration des
maisons médicales de garde les
téléconsultation ou l'orientation des
patients ne serait d'ordre législatif ou
n'aurait d'impact financier l'article
l3131-1 du code à santé publique ne
serait être le véhicule commode de votre
action et je vous invite plus que
vivement inscrire à l'occasion de du
texte en séance les Melos les mesures
législatives prenant acte de vos mesures
dérogatoires madame la ministre nous
avions intitulé le rapport de la
commission d'enquête sur l'hôpital
sortir des urgences nous revendiquons au
Sénat pas sur les seuls républicains
mais très largement dans cet assemblée
la nécessité de laisser l'hôpital
respirer en lui donnant des manières
claires et durables sortir des urgences
cela voulait dire que l'homme à
l'hôpital les conditions étaient données
pour assurer correctement les soins
programmés anticiper au mieux les soins
non programmés en ville comme à
l'hôpital cela voulait dire marquer la
règle de l'enchaînement de crise qui ne
permettent pas aux soignants de faire
leur travail dans de bonnes conditions
pour les patients comme pour eux or je
le regrette je ne vois pas l'ouverture
de cette session le chemin que le
gouvernement entend proposé sur ce point
je vous remercie même la présidente
[Applaudissements]